- Hi everyone, welcome
to Homeroom with Sal.
We have a very exciting show
and very exciting guest today,
Eric Schmidt, but before we
jump into that conversation,
I will give my standard announcements.
First, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization
and we can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So, if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations
that stepped up over the last few months.
Many of them have been
supporting us over the years,
but especially when they saw that
we were running at a deficit pre COVID
and our costs went up because of COVID,
we've had 250% of typical traffic,
a special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis
for helping us fill that gap
but we still need more
help, especially for 2021.
So please think about making a gift.
I also wanna make a reminder announcement
that there's a version of this
live stream that you can get
wherever you get your podcast
Homeroom with Sal The podcast.
So with that, I am super
excited to introduce our guest,
Eric Schmidt.
Eric there's a lot of
things folks know about you,
you are a former CEO of Google,
you were an executive chairman of Google,
you're an advisor to Google,
you're actually a former
board member of Khan Academy,
you've been a supporter of
Khan Academy over the years,
thank you for joining us.
- Well, thank you Sal and
you know, when we first met
and you had this little
operation in Mountain View,
I knew the impact that you
would have would be fantastic
but the combination of a new set of tools
and frankly, the pandemic
has accelerated you
to this sort of new level.
That's really remarkable,
so congratulations to you and the team.
I'm sure it's been intense.
- It has.
Obviously, it's been an
unfortunate situation for the world
but it's been nice that we
had something to do (laughing)
something very critical to do so.
So there's--
- Astonishing by the
way, I learned one thing,
I learned many things from
you when I was on your board,
but I don't know if you remember
when you first this
idea of looking at math
and trying to figure out which
the minimum number of math questions
to get the maximum amount
of knowledge transferred
and I thought that was
a great public service
to all students by the Khan Academy.
And so the fact that you could back solve
to what math exercises you have to do
would have saved me an
enormous amount of time
when I was learning math.(chuckles)
- Well, you seem like
you've done just fine
and I'm flattered because back in the day,
I thought all of the learning
was coming towards me.
So I'm glad a little bit went
upstream (loughs) to you.
So there's a ton to talk about
and I encourage everyone
watching on YouTube and Facebook
put questions in the message boards,
we have team members who
are gonna surface them
to Eric and myself, literally
about anything and everything.
But one of the things
where I wanna start is
on a pretty powerful
project you're working on
and actually I'm collaborating with you on
called, the RISE Program or
the RISE Scholars program.
Tell us what this is
and why you decided to
get involved in this.
- Well, it's interesting
that I tried to figure out
when I left Google, what
was really important
and it turns out the most
important thing was talent.
And I was talking to my various friends
and I said well, how did you know
that you were unique in this area?
That's code for, are
you a nerd in this way,
and they said that
roughly what happened was
when they were a teenager,
which is an awkward time for everybody,
there was some kind of teacher
or mentor or experience
that got them to understand
that they had a special gift.
So then talking to
everybody, we had this idea
of building an app, which we
ultimately asked you to build
so thank you for that.
They would try to identify students
in that sort of 15, 17 age
group with exceptional talent
and I don't just mean math though,
I mean any kind of talent,
but they're really off the charts amazing.
And the idea was that that if we did this,
what we would do is we would,
figure a way to get a list for such people
and then working with the Rhodes Trust,
we would figure out a way to identify,
starting with a hundred of them.
So you're part of this grand experience.
- No, I wanna emphasize how
excited I am about this project.
I mean, you're seeing here on the screen,
some of these students who
are able to submit submissions
and one of the really
powerful things, I mean
I think what you touch on is,
there's these super young
people around the world
and you, myself, we
were all probably lucky
early in our life to have
certain people really believe us
and certain people support us
and if we can create a framework
so that they can feel supported,
selfishly speaking, these
are the young people
who are going to cure the diseases,
who are gonna solve the
major social problems,
who are going to be the
entrepreneurs, the artists
that that really move society forward.
On your on your title, oh, go ahead, Eric.
- Well, what happened was,
so we wanted around, we
talked to you and your team,
we talked to some other teams
and there are groups
that do a pretty good job
of surfacing talent,
but they are not uniform across the world.
So, became clear that there was talent
that was not being found.
And so the insight was,
it's pretty reasonable
that that pretty much any teenager
has access to either
their own mobile phone
or someone near them has
them pretty much everywhere.
So we had the idea which again,
I think it was really your idea
of let's have them start by
submitting videos, right?
Because a video is hard
for them to fake, right?
and it's a good project
to get them, who are they?
What do they care about?
What is special about them?
So that's the grand experiment.
- Yeah, I remember when
we first started talking
over a year ago and your
your team reached out
and they said, hey, we're interested
in finding these really
high potential kids
around the world,
maybe a lot of them are using Khan Academy
and I said yes, a lot of them very well
could be using Khan Academy
and maybe a lot of them
are watching this right now
but I said, what would
be really cool is if
we could capture your traditional
academic content mastery,
whatever you wanna call,
things that traditional
test scores measure
'cause that's important
and honestly, Khan Academy
prepares a lot of that.
You have things like SATs,
which were we partner with
but then there's other things
that traditionally aren't measured,
like your sense of humor, your creativity,
your entrepreneurship and
we brainstormed together
and said, let's create this app
and the app is called hello world
where we have essentially have challenges.
Actually you have a challenge there
on how someone can change the world.
I put a challenge on there where
people need to figure out
ways to make me laugh.
And when they submit the video
they also get to review
other people's videos
and help them on their journey
to, to grow themselves.
And what we're hoping is that
not just for the RISE program,
but this could be a new way
of folks being able to show who they are
showcase who they are and
get access to opportunities.
You know, one thing that I'm sure
a lot of folks are
thinking about is, well,
what does this mean?
Let's say, let's say I run.
I won, I become a rise scholar.
I'm one of that hundred this year
what what's going to happen to my life?
- Well, hopefully, the first thing.
So at some point the
pandemic will be over.
And at that point, that cohort will be
we'll have some kind of
residential program, you know
three or four weeks together
which we think will be transformative.
What we know is that each person has
a specialized set of
problems and opportunities.
So we'll start with trying to make sure
that they're operating
at their full potential
with career and career and
college counseling and so forth.
If they need a way to get
into a university in the U S
we'll find a way.
These are people who will
get into wherever they apply
but we wanna encourage
them to apply wherever
as part of this, we've made a commitment
that it's a lifelong program.
So over time we'll provide
mentoring and help.
And we'll also take the older recipients
and use them to mentor,
mentor the younger ones.
Because of the way our model works,
we are also gonna start tracking
whether the signals that your app produces
ultimately are predictive
of future behavior.
So the key thing is that we're
we have an idea of what shows excellence
and there's some anecdotal
data, but oversee a decade.
We'll be able to say these
cohorts and these characteristics
are the most likely to
predict future success
with the help we're providing.
So that's really interesting to me.
- And, and I really wanna emphasize this.
I've been telling, you know,
every young person that I meet
who I think could, you
know, have a chance of this.
I was like, you have to look
seriously at this program.
I think you said it in a very light way,
but, you know, students who win this,
they're going to get
access to a lot of mentors,
a lot of support once again, not just now
and through college, but
for the rest of their lives.
If they have ideas
on how to help humanity,
they wanna start a business.
They wanna start a not-for-profit
essentially you're creating an ecosystem
for, to support them.
- We are and let's discuss,
what will the world look
like in 25 or 50 years?
they're gonna be more people.
It's also gonna be more complicated.
Humans are really good
at building complex governance systems
political systems, social systems.
So this next generation of
neat leaders are needed now.
And they have to be
up to the task of an even more complicated
and interconnected world.
And I'm excited about that.
I think that my general view is
the sooner we can turn the current regime
over to a younger generation who can
you know, fix the mistakes we've made
and make some new ones,
I think the better.
- And you, you know, and I
forgot it's my bad, you know
you're the co-founder of Schmidt Futures
and Schmidt Futures is kind of the creator
of this RISE program.
Explain what Schmidt Futures
hopes to do generally speaking
and how rise fits in that.
- Well it's become the vehicle to express
the things that I care about,
which started off with talent.
We're also spending a lot
of time funding science.
There's a new generation of scientists.
There always is.
And they are accelerating
discoveries in key aspects
of science, medicine, math,
those sorts of things.
And I'm funding at a very
large level, so forth.
I'm getting very interested
in the notion of creating
institutes around new problems.
So for example, we've
created a virtual Institute
that's a code for a funding system
to look at the really
hard science problems
and climate change.
I'm not talking about dealing with it.
I'm talking about why we still
don't understand, for example
the relationship of sea
ice and the sea around it
and exactly why it melts the way it does,
these sorts of things.
There's plenty of science to be done,
and I'm trying to fund it.
And especially since the
government is now funding R and D
at the lowest percentage
since Sputnik 1.7%.
So literally, what is it?
70 years later, it's the same
percentage of GDP for science.
That's insane, right?
Nevertheless, that's where we are.
So this is an opportunity
for private philanthropy.
I'm also extremely interested
in learning and frankly,
this came out of a, I
don't know if you remember,
but you had an event at your house
before when we could have events in houses
where we talked a lot about education,
you were with bill Gates,
who's a big funder of
Khan Academy as well.
And one of the ideas there was
to try to build the database
of, of information about how people learn.
So that's called learning
engineering, and it turns out
we have lots of opinions
about how people learn
but we don't actually
have any provable data.
We don't have any AI science around this.
So I'm trying to fund that as well.
- That's a pretty bold goal.
I mean, you know, if I
read between the lines
it's really, you're stepping up
and you are stepping up in massive ways
to kind of help fill this gap that,
that normally is done by
nations and governments.
You know, what, what we're in a
obviously a very unique time
with the political environment
with COVID, with what's going
on, on, you know work and,
and remote work and all of that.
What, and given your, your org, you know
Schmidt Futures, what is
your sense of the future
for looking back five years
from now, 10 years from now
what do you think is gonna
change for the better
and what do you think is
gonna change for the worse?
- Well, I, I don't mean
to say it the obvious
but when historian looks
when historians look
at the West performance
with respect to the pandemic,
they're going to give us an F.
Democracy as it's currently
formulated is not serving
the health and the health
and safety of the citizens
of Europe and of South America
and of the United States.
There are a few democracies in Asia,
primarily that have managed
to get through this.
There's a couple in Europe,
but otherwise it's been a disaster.
The reason I'm hammering on this
is that the compound negative
impact of the pandemic,
especially on minorities
and the underserved
is going to be hard for us to catch up.
I thought things were going
pretty good before the pandemic
things were getting better.
But if you look at ratios of inequality,
the issues of education and so forth,
one of the reasons that
Khan Academy is so important
is there's evidence that
especially students of color,
people who without, without proper means
are literally going to miss out
of a whole year of education
because the schools are
closed or partially open.
So we've got to collectively
solve this problem.
The future of our nation is at stake.
Having said that as sort
of the number one concern,
there's all sorts of reasons to think
that the, the model of
entrepreneurial discovery,
the kind of creativity that we're doing
is going to accelerate
for all sorts of reasons.
So if we can just get
through this pandemic,
with minimal loss of life
and get people back to school and to work.
Which somehow the, at least
the Trump administration
seems to have forgotten
to focus on at the moment.
And we're waiting now on
that Biden transitioning,
which is two months away which is insane,
during the middle of a pandemic.
But nevertheless, I think
that's where we are.
There's every reason to think
that we can make great progress
in biology and chemistry
in mental health, in use of tele-health.
I mean, there's an example after example.
I'm the chairman of the
re-imagined commission
for New York state.
And we've looked a lot at
what the future looks like.
And once you have relatively
broadly available broadband
it's possible to have a
somewhat more effective
and somewhat more efficient
learning experience
on an entertaining experience, et cetera.
I'm not one of these people
who thinks we go back.
I think we go forward
and the new world is much
more hybrid as an aside.
One of the things that
the pandemic has proven
is that people can be
productive working from home
if they choose to.
So it looks to me
like we've got some new fundamental
learnings in our society
which are probably positive
after this terrible experience.
- And there's a lot in that.
I mean, I'm just the second
to last thing you mentioned
that I wanna get to the
last thing you mentioned.
The notion of essentially
access to broadband
and the digital divide, what's yours?
And, you've had ties to government
and probably talking
to them, advising them,
obviously your role at Google.
What, what do you think are the chances
that we can finally close
the digital divide at home?
I mean my back of the envelope,
it would be one to 2%, of one
of these rounds of stimulus
would essentially do the job.
What do you think our odds are?
- That's why, that's why the
current situation is insane.
The government is being forced
because of economic activity,
come up with a number of
trillion dollar bailouts.
All we need is 50 billion
a hundred billion to both wire
up the rest of the country
and fund all the rapid testing,
fund all the Sentinel systems,
fund all the knowledge
systems to keep us safe.
And yet every time this comes
up, it doesn't get funded.
There's something wrong here.
There's somebody, some,
some cognitive problem.
But in any case in our New York work,
we discovered that there
are hundreds of thousands
of households in New York state
that have, do not have
effective access to broadband.
Now, you might say there's
plenty of rural people
and the rural people suffer
because their primary access is cellular.
So literally on a cell phone
but there are many, many
underserved communities
within the cities of our nation.
And it's just, it's just stupid.
It's basically because
the prices are too high.
There's no subsidy or there are subsidies,
but the people are not aware of it
or the build out has not
completed and so forth.
And we've got to address that.
So as part of our commission,
we're making a set of recommendations
which essentially say, in
order to operate going forward
you have to embrace universal broadband
and you have to measure it.
I'll give you a simple example.
Under the FCC rules, you
can count connectivity
based on a single household
within a zip code.
In other words,
the coverage looks a lot
better than it really is.
And so we proposed example crowdsourcing
the actual coverage maps.
So we can figure out who
actually has broadband.
And you'll be surprised
where the holes are.
Here, I'm in New York city
New York city, and you spend
a lot of time in New York.
New York has plenty of holes.
It's easy to cover if you want to.
- That's fascinating.
And what, what's your sense?
You know, assuming we
are able to cover it.
And I, the silver lining
I've never seen more energy
than we're seeing right now
at hopefully closing the
Jill divide, you know
kind of your, your, your last
point that you had made around
the future of work and that people realize
that they can be reasonably
productive remote,
you know, given your vantage point is,
former CEO of, you know, the
techiest of tech companies
that has a lot of infrastructure for,
that allows people to work remotely.
What, what do you think is gonna happen
to work and, and business
travel and all of that?
- Well, there's a couple
of interesting statistics.
One is that only about
30% of the workforce
can effectively work from home.
Think about the number of people
who were insecurity guards.
They open doors.
There have to be in some kind
of manufacturing facility
to oversee something.
They're teachers who have to
be in a classroom, et cetera.
There's so many jobs
which are not able to work
from home at the moment.
And for those who wish to work from home,
some of them don't have
environments as we discussed
where they have appropriate broadband
or maybe they don't even
have a working environment
where they can do their work
because they live in a
relatively cramped place,
which wasn't a problem but now it is
because they have no space to,
to focus on what you
and are talking about.
So I think these things will adjust.
And I think the most important thing is
that we're not gonna go back
to the structured nine
to five in the office.
It's going to be more flexible.
They're gonna be more hybrid models.
Also, and I don't mean
to be a downer on this,
but the pandemic will
go on for a long time.
Even if you make the most
most positive assumptions
about vaccine effectiveness
and so forth, the rate at
which the vaccine works
the number of people who will get it
then the effectiveness of the vaccine
in terms of length of time,
it means that we're gonna be operating
in this strange hybrid mass model
for probably more than a
year from now, maybe longer.
So we need to have a plan to get our
to get our businesses back to work,
to get our students educated
to have our mental health address,
and frankly to have some
fun and enjoy our lives
during this period.
- No, it's fascinating.
And there's so much that that's in flux.
So we're getting a ton of
questions on Facebook and YouTube.
So the first question from Facebook,
Mandy Robie, do students apply
them they're asking this is,
I guess, is about the RISE program.
Do students apply themselves
or do they have to be nominated?
I can take that, but if you wanna.
- And the answer is both.
You can nominate yourself
and you can be nominated by somebody.
And there is an app
entitled Hello World - Rise,
which is available on Google Play
and on the Apple App Store.
And I encourage people to download it.
And I wonder who wrote that app Sal.
- Yeah, just for everyone you knows.
We mentioned earlier,
this app is a project.
It's a, it's actually a cousin
project of Khan Academy.
It's another, non-for-profit
called Hello World.
And I'm the chairperson of it.
But I've been working very
closely with that team
to think about, you know
in a world where Khan
Academy can have people
learn at their own pace
kind of core academic
things, have supports
ideally do it in a classroom setting
but also be able to do it on their own.
How does someone prove
who they are to the world?
And Hello World is that app.
And I encourage anyone
listening to apply to that.
You know, sometimes folks might say
Oh wow, there's gonna be a
hundred kids in the world.
Maybe I'm not one of those hundred kids,
but I encourage you.
This app is going to look at dimensions
of your personality that you
might not have appreciated yet.
And that we might appreciate
if you're really funny
if you creative, if you, it's not
just your traditional assessments.
Now we are also gonna be looking at
people who are off the
charts and, you know,
in traditional measures as well.
But encourage everyone to apply.
And even if this year, you're not able to
get the RISE program, just
going through the process of,
of going to the app and
going to these challenges
we're hoping over time to
connect students, all of y'all
with other opportunities as well,
opportunities, other scholarships,
higher education opportunities and jobs.
So encourage everyone to
download the Hello World app
and apply.
- And Sal you and I I've
talked about this before
but I really like you to take this app
that you guys have built
and use it for more general assessments,
self assessment by students,
as we learn what's great about people.
Maybe this app can help you
provide a better experience
in your learning programs
and also better referrals.
So I think the platform
you built is well broader
than what RISE is offering.
And I think you could pull that off.
- That, that's what we're hoping.
And, you know, that's what,
we're very excited about working with RISE
is kind of the first end
goal for, for the app
because as we said, and
I think, you know, you're
you're, you're being very humble
with what this program is.
I mean, you know, I'm
telling every young person
if my, if my older son
was a little bit older
I'd be like, you're
applying for that tonight.
(laughs)
because.
- We've been waiting for your
kids to grow up for a while.
You know, can we talk
about your kids all day?
- Hey, no, no nepotism.
It would be on their own merits,
but this is a great program
for anyone who, honestly
anyone who just goes through
the process of applying.
I think it's going to be
a really powerful thing.
You're going to have artifacts
that are gonna be able to
show folks to impress them
and get opportunity.
And then for the folks
who become finalists
and the folks who get become
part of the scholars program
I, this is genuinely
going to be life-changing
and you get to be part of that,
that first class of people that
that are going to be
heavily, heavily invested in.
So there's other questions
coming in over here.
Oh whoops, I dropped my, my headphones.
So one question here and
we touched on a little bit,
but maybe we'll double
down those from YouTube,
SmartBear five asks,
how will Schmidt Futures
change the future?
You mentioned you know, some things
and kind of scientific discovery
filling the gap of government,
you know, in your dream,
but still, you know, reasonably pragmatic.
And, you know, how do you hope
that the future will be different
because of Schmidt Futures
let's say in 20 years?
- Well, what I hope is true is
that we have an unusually
good model for talent.
In other words that we can
just somehow feel the talent
better than others.
And so we collect these teams together.
So what I'm particularly excited about
which I'm working on now
is try to identify the really
hard problems in society.
I'll give you one, inequality.
The inequality is getting worse.
How is this, okay?
It's clearly not.
I'm very interested in
moving the AI platforms
beyond their current technology based to
more aggressive uses of AI in
terms of knowledge learning.
I'm very interested in using
AI to approximate functions
that have never been computable before.
This occurs in chemistry
and physics and biology.
I'm very, very interested in the progress
that people can make in
biological systems, now.
It used to be that you had
to sort of manually adjust
where you thought the
targets of drugs were
and how the various
components of biology work.
And now you can use synthetic
synthesis programs that
will actually do this.
There's evidence of people
who can use synthetic biology
at scale now to build parts of life
that will be helpful for human existence.
And I can just go on and on and on.
- I can, I can talk to you for an hours
about pretty much every clause
of what you just say, what
you just talked about.
I mean, you know, just, just to underline
some of what you said, I mean,
it sounds like this work
just even one dimension
that last dimension you
referred to, this good.
We could accelerate the
number of drugs we discover
and make them more effective
by an order of magnitude or two.
I mean, that's just,
that would be a massive
- So, so it's interesting
that there's a drug
that was just developed called Holocene.
It was developed by a group at MIT
and the group had a synthetic
biologist who was brilliant
and a computer scientist who is brilliant,
and a number of other
chemists who are brilliant.
And they work together as a
team for a couple of years
to actually build a drug
that appears to be a
new class of antibiotics
that was discovered by computer.
If that is a replicable model, right?
So with here's a proof point,
then it looks like a
whole bunch of problems
that have been deviled
humanity for a very long time.
We'll be close to following.
We'll see, of course, drugs
take a long time to develop
and they have to be safe, and all of that.
- That's mind blowing.
And just to explain everyone
watching, cause you know
there's a lot of young people
here try to figure out,
what do I do with my life?
What is a synthetic biologist?
Explain what that is
how's that different
than a regular biologist.
- Okay, synthetic biologist is
the creation of what you think of as life.
That is carbon, carbon
consuming cells, if you will
Using essentially a computer
and there are techniques
where the cells are essentially combined
and you get something
which is a life form.
Now by the way, we're not
creating humans with us,
we're dealing with, you know, tiny little
tiny little things
but those tiny little
things can be, for example
put as part of a drug to
help some biological process,
they can also be used to detect things.
So the, for various
biology is very powerful
and we're just learning
how powerful it is.
And so for things like, I
don't know, the classic example
in synthetic biology is,
fuels that do not have carbon in them.
In other words, synthetic fuels.
And that's another example.
Today synthetic biology
is primarily focused on
new drug categories
'cause frankly that's
where all the money is.
- No, that's that's, I mean
it's mind blowing me even
when you talked about
that not only are you kind
of synthesizing new organisms
or new molecules
but the, how does
synthesizes being informed
by artificial intelligence?
I'm assuming it's being trained on data
of what other types of
molecules have been able to do.
And as far as being an antibiotics
or something like that, and as
we will create new molecules.
- It's interesting that it's pretty clear
that 30 years ago,
if someone asked you what
fields you should get into it,
the correct answer was computer science
computer science has sort
of taken over the world
in terms of it's now the number one major
in most universities it's
accepted as a mainstream activity.
Whereas 30 years ago it was
sort of crazy people like me.
It was seen as sort of sought on the side,
now it's mainstream.
What's the next one.
It's clearly biology
because biology is so deep
so powerful and so poorly understood
at the molecular level,
at the processes level,
once you, so here's an example
we can't build a fully functioning model
of a digital cell yet,
think about it we should
be able to do that.
There are teams that are now
trying to build small models
of human, not human, but mouse
brains and things like that.
Again we're off by an order of magnitude
of the ability to do it.
The biological world is
so much more complicated
than I thought and is likely
to be chippable a wayable
whatever the word is. (indistinct)
Because of the advances
of the technologies that I'm describing.
So to me, if I were to give
advice to a young person,
if you can do biology and
biology is fascinating,
there's a heavy math component.
Again, just touch up on your math.
But the fact the matter is
that's where the money is gonna be
in the same sense that it
used to be computer science.
- Yeah, and that sounds like, I mean
it's really the convergence of these two
because it's really the
computing that is allowing us
because biological processes
have been so unfathomably complicated.
And you know, you mentioned the cell
and know there's a video on Khan Academy.
I still remember doing this
where I had it like this,
this, you know, we have
this image of the cell
of a lot of foot books
have this very simple thing
with the nucleus, but
the reality of a cell
it's like a whole universe in there
and the complexity of how it
works, it's mind boggling.
But the fact that we can
start to understand it.
- I'm funding a project, a large project
which has not yet been announced
to try to understand how
the cells communicate
with each other.
Think of it as the biology of life.
We don't even understand the signaling
between the various
components of the cell.
We sort of, we can see the
cell, we can name the parts.
The micro microscopes are really good
but we don't understand how
the transformations occur.
And the theory is that there's
probably a unifying language.
It's one that we haven't discovered yet
which is built by God and by nature,
which is at the basis of all of that.
Now that's cool.
- No, it is, it is mind-blowing.
I can't tell you how many times
that even when I was
trying to cover the biology
for Khan Academy, which is, you know
apparently, you know,
entry-level college level biology
or high school level biology
that sometimes it was like
okay, the textbook says A leads to B,
but why does that really, really happen?
Then I'd call some friend who's, you know
a professor at Johns Hopkins
or Duke or MIT or Stanford.
And they say actually, Sal,
you just stumbled on a cutting edge.
You know, we don't know
the answer to that.
And it's exactly what you described.
We don't, there's so much that we don't
you know, we're a big
bag of trillions of cells
and we really just don't
understand that at all.
- But I think for your, for
the students that you work with
you know, your customer base if you will,
the most important thing
to understand is that
there's so much going on,
that's sexy and interesting
in these fields,
but if you get it all interested
in and just run at them
and Khan Academy has
all the initial information that you need.
And if it wets your appetite
then online, you, so too, you know
in my case, I was interested in computers
when I was a sort of 15 year old,
I would have had the internet
exists which it didn't,
I would have been deeply
into it as a 16 year old
cause I was so interested,
I would have spent all night
just playing with it, playing games
learning how it worked,
experimenting with it.
That possibility is now in front of you
in all of these fields.
- No, it's really mind-blowing.
And I see how it all fits together
because of Schmidt Futures is
both working on the technology
and the processes and the
science of the future.
And also the pipeline of
everyone, not just in science
but the people who are going
to be able to make the change
because it's not just gonna be a science
that has to be forwarded.
And technology is going to be policy.
It's going to be the arts.
Everything is going to need to evolve.
And that's what y'all are,
what we, we're trying to find
with the rise fellows.
- But one of the things that you saw
is that in order to do what you do,
you have to be insanely curious.
So a good rule of life for
again are our constituencies,
our customers our students, what have you
is just keep asking questions
and challenge assumptions.
I hate it when people say
well, the following is true
and I check it and it's not.
And I said, look, right
here is the evidence.
And then they're so stuck on their idea.
They don't realize there's an alternative
it's called critical thinking.
So as you explore these fields,
the critical thinking
that you will develop
will be so powerful in terms of your life,
your ability to you know,
and when the government
does something stupid
or the media lies to you,
or somebody mislead you
or whatever, you'll be
able to say, you know what?
I actually know the answer.
I have the strength of my own convictions
'cause I've done the research.
I can do the critical thinking
and I know what is true,
and I'm gonna pursue this
'cause I'm passionate about it.
And that's when greatness happens.
- No, it was very powerful.
And just to close out,
these conversations always
go much faster than I expect.
I just looked at it as like, Oh,
we're almost out of time, you know?
And you already touched on this,
but there's a lot of 15
to 17 year olds listening
or even younger, a little bit older.
There's a lot of their parents,
a lot of teachers listening.
What advice do you have
for these young people?
I mean, you touched on it a little bit.
If you were, if you know of
the younger version of yourself
when you were 15 or 16,
but it's 2020, what would,
what would you tell them?
- Try to learn calculus.
I know that's a boring answer,
but it's actually true.
If you can master calculus
you don't have to even be good at it.
If you at least understand calculus
then you'll have the critical thinking
and the analytical
capabilities to do economics
the law, any of the
sciences, any of the math,
any of the things that I care about
So to me, if you can get yourself
to the point where you
can do calculus and again,
Khan Academy is fantastic on this stuff.
I think it will have a huge impact.
So, you know it's the old
thing of in the graduate movie
way back when and he said,
the answer is plastics.
So my answer is calculus.
- No, that's super fun.
I didn't expect you to say
that, but I love your answer
because one, I also love calculus
and Khan Academy is a
great place to learn that.
And you're absolutely right.
Even if you don't take a derivative
or an integral in your future life,
it shows that you have the kind
of the analytical capability
to think fairly deeply about things.
And today there are supports to do it.
You can learn at your own time,
and based on Khan Academy, practice videos
we actually have another effort
another cousin effort
called schoolhouse.world
where you can actually get
free tutoring for calculus.
And then you can prove what you know
and then become a tutor yourself.
And that can lead you to opportunities.
And then obviously on
Hello World, you can apply
whether it's your calculus,
your science skills
your computing skills, your
creative, artistic creativity
to lead to opportunity.
What will our, you know,
I could talk for hours
about any one of the
sentences you mentioned today,
but thank you so much,
- Well, let me thank you Sal.
You've changed the world.
You've changed probably
a million lives already
and you're on your way to 10 million.
I admire what you've done.
Having you as a partner
is one of the great things
in my life today.
And I want to do more with you.
Thank you so much for
having me on your show.
- No, well, Eric it's, the
feeling is more than mutual.
You've been, I you were
very kind when you said
you learned something from me,
but in the early days of Khan Academy,
I remember when 60 minutes
was doing a piece on Khan Academy.
And then the producer said,
Oh yeah, we got Eric Schmidt.
And I was like, Eric
Schmidt knows who I am.
And then you, you, I mean
I remember at the end and
anyone could find it on YouTube.
At the end of the 60 minutes
piece, you were very generous
about, you know, who I was
like, that helped me believe
in myself like Eric Schmidt.
- So we're trying to
recreate that feeling Sal
that I inadvertently created a new
for a million people using
your app on the RISE Program.
That's what we want to do.
We want that feeling that
you felt that lifted you.
We want everyone to have that feeling.
Imagine if we can pull that off together.
- No, I love that, I love that.
Let's, let's do that.
And it's gonna be selfishly motivated
because these are the young people
who are going to entertain us
and drive discovery of medicines
and keep us alive longer and,
and make our lives better.
So I'm excited to go on
this journey with you, Eric.
- Okay, thanks again Sal.
- Thank you.
Well thanks everyone for joining
a super exciting conversation
on a lot of levels.
I mean, I literally
could talk to Eric about
every one of those things that
Schmidt Futures is working on
because they're there you can run
like a science fiction
story about each of them.
But I do wanna encourage
everyone listening
whether you are a teenager,
whether you know a teenager,
whether you're the parent of a teenager
or teachers of teenagers, take
a serious look at this rise.
The scholars program, as
I talked about with Eric
this is not some, let's
call it a small scholarship.
This is something that is
literally transformational
for a young person's life.
Just going through the process
of going to Hello World
and applying for it.
You can see the URL right there
risefortheworld.org/apply.
And this is the first year.
And I think when you get in on the ground
for something that's even
that much more exciting.
So encourage everyone watching to apply
and get everyone else to apply.
It's it literally is going to
be a life changing opportunity
for you.
So with that I will see you actually
I'll see you in a little while
probably after Thanksgiving break,
I'm going on a little bit of a vacation,
so I'll see you'll in.
I guess that's going to be December.
See y'all then.
(beeps)